hello I'm Mike manager and I am a
professor at the University of
Pittsburgh and we'll start this talk on
the neuroscience based approach to
restore a ssin of a sensory motor
function after spinal cord injury
presenting with me will be a Ralph
Johnson John College er my role is as
one of the lead physicians on the study
and so I will start by talking about
spinal cord injury itself so a
definition of spinal cord injury is
lesion of the neural elements in the
spinal canal so not only does that
include the spinal cord but also the
cauda equina resulting in a temporary or
permanent sensory and/or motor deficit
you can see the incidence here of
seventeen thousand patients
approximately per year the prevalence is
all those people living with the spinal
cord injury and you can also see the
injury level and we'll talk a little bit
more about the injury level as we go on
one of the important factors that will
touch on also is the average age of
participants the average age is 42 but
this is really a bimodal distribution in
terms of age in that there's usually a
young group which are risk-taking males
and they're 18 to 20 year old range 16
to 20 and then there's an older group
that's related to Falls if we talk about
the impact of a spinal cord injury it
really depends on the level and the
completeness of the injury so the spinal
cord travels in this bony structure that
you can see on the slide at a very high
level c4 is one that's depicted here you
can person can lose their ability to
breathe potentially not be able to move
their arms or hands at all and therefore
have a complete paralysis
I have lower down injury may give
partial use of the arms and and hands
and if you have any impairment or your
arms or hands it's referred to as
tetraplegia or quadriplegia injury
he's below that level so below t1 in
general are considered to be pair of a
jock meaning that the arms function
normally one can imagine that if you
have complete loss of your ability to
move your arms hands and legs that your
your complete inability to really
control your environment except for
using the cranial nerves musculature
which enables you to talk and speak but
you can't manipulate objects you can't
move objects around with a level of
injury below the point where the hand is
affected no one can live very
independent life and including bowel and
bladder function but usually that life
is led from a wheelchair and again many
spinal cord injuries are incomplete and
depending on how complete the injury is
how much strength and sensation there is
below the level of injury will determine
how much independence someone has
important as we look at this and part of
the reason we're framing the question
this way is related to cost and will
actually talk directly upon cost and you
think of cost in dollars which I will
give to you but there's also a cost and
quality of life so the long term
survival in spinal cord injury is it is
shorter than that of population without
a spinal cord injury but still fairly
long as you can see in this table if
you're injured at age 20 and and survive
past the first year that your life
expectancy you're expected to live
approximately 52 years longer or and
that you know that's a substantial
amount of life with what can be a
significant disability that life
expectancy goes down over time and while
I'm thinking that I should point out
that most of these slides and most of
this data is from the National spinal
cord injury data center which is a
project that is funded by the National
Institutes of disability and independent
living
and rehabilitation research nide ler
which funds 14 centers of excellence
that collect data on spinal injury and
then follow people with spinal cord
injury over time the University of
Pittsburgh has one of those centers but
that dataset is actually available for
anyone to answer the data set focuses on
traumatic spinal cord injury although
the technology that we're going to
discuss today actually can cover both
traumatic and non traumatic spinal cord
injury as might be seen in a condition
like MS which can uniquely impact the
spinal cord there are other conditions
that can impact the spinal cord and that
would be amenable to brain computer
interface what's you know one of the
examples of the impact of a spinal
injury is how it impacts your ability to
work or be a student and you can see
that primarily because of the age
distribution only about 57 percent of
people who sustained a spinal injury are
working when they have their spinal cord
injury and then another 15 percent are
students that retired group is likely
the group that we talked about that
would have a fall as a cause for their
injury the most important part though is
the chart at the bottom of the slide
which shows that at injury we have that
58 57 percent employment rate 15 percent
students but just one year after injury
the employment brain goes down from
fifty-eight percent to 12 percent and
really while it recovers it never gets
anywhere close to the 58 percent level
and again also as one ages there's less
likelihood of being a student but what
that means is that ten years after a
spinal injury only about 33 percent of
those people who are injured or either a
students are employed and that adds to
the cost if we go a step further than
that and we actually look at lifetime
cost you can see that depending on the
level of injury which really talks about
one type of medical care will be
required that for a high tetraplegia the
cost can be a million dollars and again
this is over five years ago so a million
in the first year and then 200,000
almost $200,000 each year thereafter and
and really that's where we're talking
about this intervention being
appropriate so lifetime costs as you can
see can exceed three to four million
dollars relatively easily for someone
who's in you're injured at 25 years old
and and you know not that much less for
someone in two years old mainly because
of changes in medical comorbidities they
might exist in an older population so it
is a popular it you know it is an injury
that results in significant disability
significant cost in terms of medical
care and then significant cost in terms
of quality of life you can imagine that
if you're dependent on people for what
you have to do every day something as
simple as drinking out of a cup of water
that and have to ask for help with that
that that would actually impact your
your quality of life your enjoyment and
what you get to do both from a work
perspective and from unplayed
perspective I should mention that having
said that um you know one of the things
from this research is that often we have
a difficult time recruiting subjects
into the studies that you're going to
hear and so two points about that one of
the reasons we have such a difficult
time can be that people with spinal
injury can make a very good lashing
themselves even with high tetraplegia so
lawyers physicians including medical
students who've gone to medical school
with high spinal cord injury are out
there and so there can be a full life
even with the spinal cord injury but
that doesn't mean that we in any way
want to stop medical science and looking
at ways we can make life with a spinal
cord injury better if you look at
priorities for functional recovery and
there are many different studies that
have looked at this some variation by
how you ask the question but a very high
priority across the board is returning
our min ham function for those people
who have tetraplegia or impairment and
in an auction so if you ask them one
they'd like to do they would like to be
able to have their hand help them do
things over and over again during their
course their daily lives like those
people without disability take for
granted this is where the brain computer
interface can come in the the brain and
the cerebral cortex the part of the
brain that initiates motor movement is
intact at a spinal cord injury what is
hurt is what's inside that spinal canal
the spinal cord itself so all of the
thought process that goes into thinking
I want to reach for this cup of water I
have an itch that I want to scratch all
of that all of those signals should be
something that we can tap into in the
brain and it's exactly that that is part
of what we want to do also and very
importantly I've been talking in terms
of motor function but the other thing
that is impacted in in most spinal cord
injuries is your ability to feel so not
only can you not move your arms but
because the spinal injury disrupts
sensory pathways you can't feel when
sometimes someone touches you you can't
necessarily feel pain and so another
goal of a bi-directional brain computer
interface is to be able to restore
sensation and and so what you have here
is a diagram you can see that there is a
brain on the left side of the screen the
ideal scenario and one that really
mimics the human body is that as the
hand as you see here being a robotic
hand is interacting with the ball there
are sensors in the hand those sensors
follow that red path and stimulate the
brain thus restoring a feeling of
sensation in a participants own hand as
they as the robot grips the ball so the
ball is gripped the sensors on the hand
a sense that there's stimulation that
make it feel as if someone's own hand is
touching something and then based on
that touch the brain says hey I need to
grip this ball a little harder I need to
let go of the ball and the brain
computer interface
is able to decode that signal and
control the robotic hand so this is the
basis of what we're trying to do with
this study in the absence of sensation
fine motor control is really impossible
and much of the work that has been done
today and in spinal cord injury has used
visual feedback as the only sensory
feedback which is slow and obviously for
a dexterous movement something where
you'd move your fingers to manipulate a
fine object your vision is obscured by
the fingers themselves and sensation
becomes very important just taking a
step back you're going to hear about
some great work that we've done here
this is truly a team effort and that
team effort crosses many different lines
there is a clinical line and so there
have been a to to physicians myself
included varying involved in the study
the other position is Elizabeth Tyler
Kabara who's a neurosurgeon here and the
two of us have been responsible the
whole team is responsible for the health
and safety of the participant but the
two of us are take the lead and when
there's medical questions more involved
Elizabeth obviously does the surgery and
and I follow more of the day-to-day
issues that may came up come up but it's
a team of us that that are helping to
take care of our participants we have
clinical coordinators who helped us with
recruiting participants and again if you
are interested in being in this study
there will be ways to find us on the web
I'd encourage you to do so these
coordinators make sure that we're
following the rules that assure the
protection of a subject they help us
with the data gathering that we need to
do as part of the different bodies that
organize this so this study is approved
by the Food and Drug Administration and
there's very clear data collection that
we have to follow to make sure that
subject safety is is assured as part of
what we do and then we've brought other
physicians in along the way there's an
anesthesiologist that is there
when we implant an eggplant the subjects
when we put the devices in and we've
involved plastic surgeons in the study
as well and basically the whole team at
the University of Pittsburgh is here for
us as we need their help a huge
component of this and an arguably the
largest component from us pure
discipline perspective is in engineering
or bioengineering so the hardware and
software both of the robotic arms of the
recording devices of the stimulated
devices all have to be synced together
with software program we have to process
the signals that we understand what the
person's intent is when they try to move
and then we generate a huge amount of
data with every single day of
experimentation that we have and that
huge amount of data really requires that
we have the ability to store it in a
secure fashion this crosses both the
clinical and engineering across a number
of different sciences motor control
neural decoding somatic sensation neural
physiology and actually you could go on
and on related to mathematical sciences
that are necessary
finally a huge component of this is
regulatory we are appropriately
monitored monitored by the FDA
we are also monitored by the University
of Pittsburgh institutional review board
which assures protection of human
subjects here at the University and then
further because of the fact that this
study is one that has potential for
adverse effects there is an independent
data safety monitoring board that
includes physicians and engineers and
other people working in this area that
have no reporting up to the people who
are involved in the study are very
independent and further look at the
safety of what we're doing and any plans
or change any changes in plans we we
want to have happen as part of our
protocol and then finally there's been a
great deal of media attention there's a
fist bump shown here
the robotic fist is controlled by our
participant and the hand is that of the
former presidents United States Barack
Obama and and we've had significant
attention and so even the media people
we work with are attune to the study and
help us with getting our message across
and making sure that we're adequately
representing what we do so with that I
will turn it over to rob gods who is
also faculty at the University of
Pittsburgh and one of the lead the two
leads of the study together with Jack
College er thanks Mike so what I'm going
to do over the next little while is tell
you about some of the basic science that
goes into actually being able to achieve
this goal that might described about
creating a bi-directional brain computer
interface and so I'll treat two
different parts separately and then my
colleague Jen colander will come in at
the end and show you what we're able to
do when we put it all together all right
so let's get into this there's basically
two components that we need to be able
to accomplish in order to create this
bi-directional brain computer interface
one is how we read information out of
the brain how do we extract information
from the brain that we could use to then
control an arm and the second part is
how do we actually get that information
back end so I'll treat these two points
separately so when we think about
reading information from the brain or
extracting information brain really what
we're after as a way to listen to the
cells or the neurons in our brain that
are allowing us to normally control our
arm so when we think about reaching for
objects or moving around there's a
particular part of our brain that
becomes active the cells the neurons in
that part of the brain become active and
effectively control the arm now there's
a few different ways that these signals
can be extracted from the brain they
range in invasiveness from superficial
or external systems like I'm showing
here on the left the so-called EEG and
in this sort of the scenario you can
wear a cap or put a device on the head
and monitor the electrical activity of
these cell
as they become active completely
externally it's a nice approach because
it requires no surgery it's external the
challenge with it is that it's very low
resolution and it's very difficult to
actually really listen to the signals
that you want to be able to capture
although arm and hand function there's
sort of intermediate levels where we can
do a surgery in place electrodes on the
surface of the brain that's sort of an
intermediate step but what we do is
actually shown on the right here where
we intake these devices these micro
electrode arrays which I'll describe in
a little more detail on the next slide
and actually do a surgery and implant
these right into the brain itself all
right so let's look at these arrays in a
little more detail so the device we use
is the Utah or a Blackrock micro
electrode array and what this is it's a
silicon-based device each edge of this
device is about four millimeters on a
side so you can see an image of it there
on a fingernail to give you a sense of
how big this device is what's impressive
about it is that within this device that
single little device there there's
actually 100 individual little needles
or electrodes and right at the very tip
of those is an area that sits down in
the brain right beside individual
neurons in the brain and when we hook
the whole system up and I'll show you
some examples of this we can actually
listen to or record the electrical
activity of individual neurons in the
brain so these divide these each
individual electrode is about one and a
half millimeters long we coat them with
different materials depending on what we
want to do if we're listening to the
brain recording we're thinking about
read we're mostly using platinum
electrodes right now but we can use a
different material
iridium oxide when we want to actually
activate the brain or stimulate the
brain and write information in these
devices have been implanted in over 20
people around the world and so two of
those have occurred here at the
University of Pittsburgh and we'll get
into their stories a little bit and what
we've done on the scientific side with
them so this is the device we use now
when we think about we're actually in
the brain do we want to put these
devices that becomes an important
question or
or problem not all parts of the brain of
the same different parts of the brain
have specialized functions for different
sorts of behaviors and the two that were
most interested in are shown here so I'm
showing you in the red a region that we
call this medicine or that is called the
somatosensory cortex and just to have a
little closer towards the front of the
head of the eyes is a region called the
motor cortex now these two regions have
very different functions although
they're related to each other
significantly we'll get into that in a
little bit but in the motor cortex
there's neurons that when you think
about moving your arm you actually move
your arm these neurons become active
okay in the somatosensory cortex this is
the part of the brain that if you touch
your hand or frankly any part of your
body neurons here respond in different
ways depending on a part of the body has
been touched and particularly in the
somatosensory cortex we have this
somatic topic arrangement or this sort
of image or a picture of our whole body
right in the brain and that's what's
shown on the right this is often called
the homunculus and which means little
man and what we see here is different
parts of the brain even within the
somatosensory cortex do different things
and so there's a spot to go there's a
particular part of the brain that
becomes active when say your elbow is
touched a different part that becomes
active when your palm or your thumb or
your each individual finger is touched
and so on and so forth and so we can
actually identify where these are and
put our devices are micro electrode
arrays in the right spot okay so this is
the part of the brain that we're going
to now let's put it all together and
take a look at what happens when we
stick these electrodes in the brain and
we'll focus here on putting say two
devices two of these Utah or Blackrock
micro electrode arrays into the motor
cortex if we put these devices in there
and then we actually ask a person to
imagine or attempt to make movements
what we see is all these little
squiggles here so each one of these
little black squares represents one of
those electrodes in the brain and the
little gray lines represent the
electrical activity when an action
potential is fired by one of the neurons
we see a
zoomed in view of one here we can see
that this particular electrode is
actually recording two different neurons
the one here labeled an orange and
another in blue and so this is
fundamentally the signal that we're
working with each one of these little
squiggles or traces represents a single
neuron in the brain activating or firing
or generating action potential when we
think about a movement so this is what
we're working with the question next
obvious one is what do we do with this
information and so I'll walk you through
a little bit of the detail on how we
interpret these signals which we can
then use to control robotic arm and so
what we what we work with or what we
think about is this idea of directional
tuning in motor cortex and so this is a
some thoughts that were popularized or
really discovered by George Ellis and
Andy Schwartz Andy Schwartz is a faculty
member here at the University of
Pittsburgh who did a lot of the basic
science work to figure this thing out
and I'll describe this basic idea in in
this slide here right and so if we have
a monkey sitting down at a table and
moving his arm to the left or right or
up and down and we record the activity
of a single neuron in the brain what
they found is that you can see a really
substantial differences in the behavior
or the activity of that single neuron
when you make reaches in different
directions so if we move to the middle
panel here and look at this blue this
blue region what you'll see is that if
you look sort of in the upper left hand
side in the orange region you'll see all
these little black tick marks every one
of those little vertical marks or
slashes represents a single neuron
generating one of these action
potentials and you can see that when the
monkey is making a reach sort of up and
to the left there's a lot of these marks
right so this neuron becomes very very
active and in the opposite direction if
we look sort of down into the right what
we hardly see any of these marks are
mostly God and so what this particular
neuron is doing is becoming really
active when the monkey reaches up and to
the left and it becomes almost silent or
quiet when you move down in to the right
and so you can create a mathematical
relationship that describes
all the monkeys moving his arm and then
relate that to the activity of this
individual neuron and in this case what
that looks like is this small equation
down here where F represents the firing
rate or activity of a neuron and
basically this is a weighted sum or a
combination of the activity that's
driven by movements in different
directions and so the firing rate is
driven by or if you model it this way at
least is the firing rate is a function
of the velocities of the arm in the X
and y direction and this might be I
think we'll see one more equation that I
might get four equations for this talk
but then we can we can expand this idea
and add as many things as we want right
so if the monkeys just reaching on a
plate on a table like this now you can
imagine rotating the wrist or making
grasping motions and we can follow the
same basic idea that the firing rate of
a neuron is effectively the weighted sum
of the of all of these different motions
and so if we record from a lot of
neurons at the same time what we can do
is then create a decoder that turns all
of that activity into what we believe
the intention of the movement was right
so the neural activity is really modeled
as this weighted sum of the movement
intentions okay so that's kind of the
math behind this a little bit and you
can just really think of this as when
you move in a particular direction
certain neurons become highly active and
we can pick that up and then recreate
those motions all right
so we've got these arrays in the brain
we can understand what they're saying
and now what we need to do is actually
figure out what all the elements of
those individual equations work and
that's what we do in this BCI
calibration step and effectively what we
do if a person comes into the lab they
sit down we hook them up and they watch
on a on a computer screen a virtual
robotic arm making a bunch of motions
and we basically create a series of
random motions as you can move up to the
left and we can rotate the wrists open
and close the hand and sometimes there
are the objects there and we create sort
of a new set of these random motions
each day and we ask the purse
to follow along and attempt to make
those motions now they can't of course
because of the spinal cord injury but
nevertheless the key point here is that
even attempting to do it or thinking
about doing it even if your own arm
doesn't move still generates the same
pattern of activity or at least a
similar pattern of activity in the brain
one that we can understand and so this
is the calibration step that we do every
day okay now we've worked with two
people in this study today the first
subject was a 52 year old woman at the
time of implant who had a spinal
cerebellar degeneration which left her
effectively paralyzed below the neck and
she had two devices implanted in the
motor cortex the second participant was
twenty year old man at the time of
implant eyes with a spinal cord injury I
mean he actually had four devices
implanted in his brain two in the motor
cortex and two in the somatosensory
cortex and what I was what you'll see
here in the video in a moment I will be
if you put all of these pieces together
they'll see a video of this second
participant controlling a robot arm by
thinking about making motions well he'll
be doing he'll be reaching down to these
objects that are placed on the left hand
side of the table picking them up and
moving them to this raised platform and
there's a couple of really important
points here is that every aspect of this
robot is controlled only by him thinking
about it he couldn't do anything he
wants but what he's choosing to do is do
this task that we've asked him to do so
the computers not really helping at all
they're just interpreting the activity
of his brain to control the to control
the robot you'll see an example of that
I mean one of the objects where he
reaches down to pick up a rock but the
rock actually slips out of his grasp he
recovers and goes and picks it up again
and successfully completes the task so
we can go ahead and play that video and
you can take a look at it
- and so in that video you can see the
robot arm moving around and this is what
we call the action Reese it's a version
of something called the action research
arm test the air at score and we so we
basically measure how well he does and
in these two participants if we look at
their performance at completing this
task over a long time you can see on
this graph here on the x-axis is the
number of days post implant we're going
out to nearly a thousand days that their
performance is actually very good and
has maintained over these long periods
of time and so what this shows us is
that using this brain computer interface
system people are able to control robot
arms to complete functional meaningful
real-world tasks and do a pretty good
job of it all right so we talk now about
the reading so how do we extract the
information brain in order to control
the robot arm so let's talk about the
second half of this which is getting
information back into the brain so we'll
talk about here is the third of this
case force amount of sensation and by
somatic sensation I mean the sense of
touch and motion and things like that so
what I've just shown you is that we can
control these dexterous prosthetic arms
that we can control them to do many
motions at the same time but an
important point here is the person was
looking at it all the time but there are
all sorts of tasks we do in our daily
lives where vision is not the only thing
that we're using and in fact where it
becomes insufficient and I've shown some
examples of this if you want to touch
your fingers to each other on the top of
your head you can't see it so you need a
way to be able to do that another
example would be buttoning shirt buttons
this is the sort of task that you really
need high quality tactile feedback from
your fingertips in order to complete or
if you're grabbing say a Nerf ball and
you want to see how hard or soft it is
these are the sorts of things worse
amount of steps
smell sensation is really important
that's sort of a stunning example of
this really in some ways it's shown in
these two images here where on the Left
the person grabbed a match real easy
task pick a match out of the box and
light it and that's sort of the normal
scenario on the right though where you
can see her struggling with its task the
only thing that is
different is that she's had the the
fingertips have essentially been
anesthetized and so she can't feel the
objects and you can see you're really
struggling to pick up these objects
after enough time she does get it but
this sort of illustrates the challenges
involved in trying to do daily tasks if
you cannot actually feel objects you're
trying to work with and so what we've
done is to try and fix this or to
address this issue is we want to restore
and generate these sensations we do that
is by electrical stimulation brand and
so we take these same devices and rather
than recording the activity of
individual neurons what we're trying to
do is electrically stimulate them and
the idea here the concept is that if
we've forced these neurons to become
active that the person will experience
this as the sensation of touch so if we
stimulate the right neurons we can make
we can sort of create the sensation of
touch and that's in fact what we did and
so in this particular person what we
found is that when we electrically
stimulate on individual electrodes that
generates the sensation that feels like
it comes from his own paralyzed hand and
so what you can see within the middle
here is the representation of two of
these smaller electrode arrays in the
brain and where you see a color say an
orange square that's one of those
individual electrode tips that I showed
you earlier on the Utara and when we
electrically stimulate with small
currents through that device or through
that individual electrode it generates a
sensation on the similarly colored part
of his hand so you can see with these
two devices we generated sensations that
he described that the participant
described as coming from his own hand
according to the map that I'm showing
you here this is work that was really
largely done by Charlotte Fletcher who's
a former graduate student in the lab an
interesting thing here is that if we
look at where these sensations are
coming from it follows this arrangement
that we would expect to be present in
the brain and this is even after a
decade after the spinal cord injury and
so this somatic topic organization is
persistent in the brain even after a
decade and we can
use that or leverage that for the
purposes of this device I'm by the way
this was the first time that this kind
of its study had ever been done in
person before and one of the questions
we were really interested in was how
stable would this be over time there was
you know it was uncertain whether micro
stimulation in the brain would be able
would work for a long time and so what
this slide shows here is that over the
course of 1,200 days as we've been
stimulating and even in fact longer now
that the organization in the brain
remains the same we're able to use it
and roughly speaking its it it doesn't
change and so 1,200 days after the
implant it still was working and you can
even argue that it's working better than
it was over the first few hundred days
of the study so again each little
colored dot represents when we stimulate
on an individual electrode what part of
the hand does the person describe a
sensation as originating from it's been
a couple of moments talking about some
of the details of this before I pass it
off to Jen to put it all together for us
here at the end one of the important
questions is we wanted to know
effectively what the detection threshold
is so that as I mentioned before we're
using tiny pulses of electricity to
activate these neurons and a relevant
question is how much current how much
stimulation current do we need to
actually cause a sensation as it is what
we call the detection threshold and so
we can do some tests to measure this and
what I'm showing you on the left here is
if we look at all the detection
thresholds from all of the electrodes
about a hundred days after you did the
implant you can see that the median
detection threshold is about 32 micro
amps so that's 32 millionths of an amp
what's really interesting is after 500
days when we repeated this of the
detection threshold have gone down to
about 14 by craps and so we are able to
use less current to generate these
sensations as time goes on so that's a
really positive and encouraging sign for
us with the utility of this kind of a
device or interface in the long term
another thing we found is that when we
turn the stimulation amplitude up we
wanted to know what happens and what
we're showing here is that if we turn
the steam
elation amplitude off we start low and
then we go high and we ask the person to
say what do you feel what does it feel
like in fact how intense is at what we
see is a linear relationship between the
intensity of the his perception of the
stimulus and the current amplitude ins
what that means is that we know now that
if we stimulate on this electrode or
that electrode we can cause sensations
in different parts of the hat if we turn
the stimulation amplitude off that
feeling whatever he is feeling feels
more intense and so we can manipulate
the location and the intensity of
percepts that he feels come from his
hand one of the one of the last things
I'll show you here is sort of a relative
a is an important question but what does
it actually feel like we want to know
what electrical stimulation in the brain
actually feels like this is actually
quite a difficult question to ask well
in fact it's easy to ask but difficult
to get a meaningful answer to it and so
what I'm showing you here is you know
after about a year into the study we
looked at what was he telling us the
most and a lot of the electrodes felt
like pressure some like tingles some
electrics some warm and they feel
possibly natural he's not entirely sure
he's not confident that it feels totally
natural or totally unnatural and so
we're trying to figure out how to
actually create stimulation patterns
that do feel more natural and that's an
ongoing research problem so a couple of
important things though are that it's
never painful and that if any of you
have ever had electrical stimulation
done on you say you've been to the
physiotherapist or something you've had
electrical stimulation of your own skin
you know what that feels like and it
feels well you probably say electrical
an important thing here is that whatever
we're doing in the brain it doesn't
really feel like that it feels very
different in fact he describes it as
feeling very different than that sort of
surface stimulation and if we pattern
this electrical stimulation in ways that
we try to represent say being tapped on
the finger he actually says those sorts
of things that short bursts of
stimulation feel like tapping so we
bring this back together for a second
we've shown you that we can extract
information from the brain by listening
to the activity of neurons and the motor
cortex to control robot arm doing that
when we electrically stimulate in the
somatosensory court
we can create these percepts these
sensations that he feels like come from
his own paralyzed hand and we can
manipulate the location intensity and to
some degree the quality of those
sensations itself
so we've got those two individual parts
and now my colleague Jen Conger who's a
system professor with me here in the
Department of physical medicine and
Rehab at the University of Pittsburgh
will put it all together for us and see
what happens when we when we do it all
together okay thanks Rob and so as my
colleagues have been alluding to I'm
gonna tell you what happens when we try
to put these two things together motor
BCI with the somatosensory feedback and
I know that we've talked a lot about why
do we think we need some not a sensation
and a lot of the examples that have been
shown have been these more dexterous
tasks like tying shoelaces or buttoning
a button but there's a whole other class
of tasks that actually require a somatic
sensation that you might not think of
you know for example holding a cup
applying the same force for a long
period of time that requires tact on
proprioceptive feedback when you pass an
object to another person even though you
have visual feedback of that task you
really rely on your somatosensory
feedback to execute the timing of that
task well same thing for picking up
fragile objects and this is really where
we wanted to start with our
bi-directional BCI control and so I'll
talk you through a little bit of that
experiment now and so I should mention I
think Rob's already highlighted Sharlene
Fletcher as being sort of the leader of
some of these experiments with
significant input from John Downey and
Jeff Weiss former grad students in the
lab as well and so Mike introduced the
scheme of the bi-directional VC I can at
the beginning of the experiment just to
reiterate here we've got our participant
who's seated in their power wheelchair
looking at the robotic arm that's
positioned off to the side when
recording activity from the motor cortex
and decoding that control the endpoint
blasts of the arm here what we're going
to show is three dimensional movements
and space of the arm as well as
orientation of the wrist and opening and
closing the hands and so all of that
will be under continuous and
simultaneous control other participant
at the same time recording from the
torque sensors in the robotic arm and we
are transforming that into stimulation
patterns for electrodes that are
implanted into somatosensory cortex so
as they squeeze an object harder
the amount of stimulation amplitude or
the intensity of that stimulation will
increase during the experiment the first
question that we asked was can I see
master intra cortical micro stimulation
improve object transfers so the task is
very simple they have a horizontal
workspace in front of them that's shown
here and the gray the red and the green
an object is positioned on the left hand
side of the workspace and what we call
the grasp stone they need to move the
robot to the left
pick it up lift it over the transport
zone and set it down in the release zone
and then the experimenter one quickly
moves it back to the grasp zone and they
try to do that as many times as they can
in two minutes
and so the way that we structured this
experiment was first we did four days of
those tasks with ICMS and then four days
without and importantly the participant
had been doing this type of task for
more than two years you know with visual
feedback primarily throughout the
experiment prior to these studies we did
five trials of this task per day each of
them lasting two minutes and again the
goal is just to complete as many object
transfers as possible within those two
minutes and it turns out that ICMS did
improve performance on this task so
without stimulation across all of those
trials he was able to complete 315
transfers as compared to 352 with
stimulation and if you break that down
into the the two minute long trial
without stimulation that's 15.8
transfers and with stimulation 17.8
which reduces the time for transfer by
about a second and so to give you a
sense of what this looks like what I'm
showing you here is sort of that
horizontal workspace again but now we're
looking at a heat map where the
intensity of that color is telling you
on average for a trial how long did the
participants spend with the robotic arm
in a particular area of the workspace so
we look at the graphed on the Left first
where he was performing the task without
ICMS you can see in the grasp zone you
know there's this centre of activity
he's shown in yellow around where the
object was you remember the task is to
pick it up move it through the transport
zone and release it and so you see that
there's a lot of time spent hovering on
the left side of the workspace near the
grasp zone particularly when you compare
it to the right the figure on the right
where there's never quite that intense
yellow that you see on the left meaning
he didn't spend as much time in that
grass zone you might also notice that
there's more variability in the area of
the work space that he explored without
ICMS and so we can quantify this if you
look at the amount of time that he spent
in each of these zones that I've defined
the biggest improvement by far was seen
in the grasp zone so he was able to
decrease the amount of time then he
spent in the grasp zone by about a
second which is you know doesn't sound
like a lot but it's really a 30%
decrease in the amount of time that he
was spending trying to grasp that object
there was no significant difference the
amount of time it took him to transport
the object across the workspace but then
in the release we also saw a slight
decrease of about a half a second or 18%
in that release zone as well and so we
wanted to know what actually caused the
reduction in that time that was spent in
the grasp zone and so we quantified the
distance that the arm was traveling
within that that grasp zone prior to
object contact and when he had
stimulation you can see there in the
blue histograms this is showing the
number of trials for a given path length
the blue trials tend to cluster on the
left hand side meaning that he was
traveling less of a distance in that
grasp zone than without stimulation
which is shown in gray and so overall he
was moving about 12 centimeters less per
transfer when he had stimulation it's
again this means that when he was
approaching the object rather than
trying to reposition the hand for an
appropriate grasp he was able to quickly
cross the object and move to the
transfer phase and brought briefly
introduced the action research arm test
which we've used a lot in our studies
it's commonly used to evaluate motor
performance after a stroke because it
measures unilateral arm function and so
here for these experiments we tested
nine of the 19 possible tasks so the
goal is to pick up four different size
cubes a sphere a rock to different sized
cylinders and also to perform a water
pouring task but you can see in the
picture and the right essentially the
object is placed in the left hand side
of the workspace the user moves the
robot arm to the object grasps it picks
it up and move puts it on a raised
platform and for the scoring they'd this
time to each object on a given day three
times the best of those attempts was
scored from zero to three where a score
of zero me
that they were unable to complete any
movement which that school never
occurred a one that the task was
partially completed able to touch the
object two is that they were able to
complete that grass transport and
release somewhere less than two minutes
and then three means that they completed
that task in less than five seconds and
five seconds is what's considered a
normal collation time for an able-bodied
person we did tell the participant that
their completion times would be recorded
for all of the trials to calculate an
overall success rate and completion time
per trial and so again on this task and
we saw improved performance with
stimulation and so what I'm showing you
here in this graph first I'm showing you
what the scores that the participant was
able to achieve really over the two
years prior to these experiments where
most of these experiments were done
without somatosensory feedback as shown
in gray a few times we did try providing
sensory feedback shown in blue with
different settings than what we're
tested here usually a single channel of
stimulation but what you see is that
when we moved to the ICMS experiments
shown in the middle column here the
score improved over all of the scores
that he had achieved over the past two
years and then when we took that away
for the final four sessions it returned
back down to the baseline level and so
to give you an idea of what these scores
mean you know his prior performance the
median score was an 18 which based on
our scoring scheme you know typically
would be achieved by completing all of
the tasks successfully but in under two
minutes because we have nine tasks each
of them were scored in two with ICMS the
score was a twenty-one which means that
he was able to perform some of those
tasks at least three of them in under
five seconds which is considered a
normal able-bodied time and again after
removing ICMS for the last four sessions
the scores went back down to the
baseline level so again if we look at
how long did it take him to complete
these tasks here I'm showing you a
histogram of the number of trials he was
able to complete within different time
periods and so without ICMS the median
completion time was twenty nine twenty
point nine seconds out of all of the
successful trials that were completed
but when we gave him sensory feedback
you can see that the completion times
are much lower because the histogram has
shifted towards the left and the median
time there was
10.2 seconds so we're able to cut the
completion time for successful trials in
half essentially even with this fairly
simple encoding scheme and importantly
15 out of the hundred eight trials that
he attempted were completed in under
five seconds something that he had not
achieved previously without ICMS
feedback so to break this down a little
bit further again we looked at how to
dis actually impact the tasks in the
different phases it's the first phase is
the reach phase of starting from the
home position and reaching to initially
touch the object we did see a little bit
of a decrease here of 0.6 seconds which
was a 27% decrease in that amount of
time the biggest change just like in the
object transfer task really came from
grasp so that time from initially
contacting the object to picking it up
and starting to initiate that transfer
and so here we saw that the median time
decreased from thirteen point eight
seconds to five point eight seconds
which was a 44% reduction in time spent
and transport there was a very slight
reduction in the amount of time that was
spent actually moving it over to the
raised platform so to give you a sense
of what this looks like after this we'll
play a video showing you for each of the
different objects what was the fastest
trial he was able to achieve with ICMS
feedback shown on left on the left and
without ICMS feedback shown on the right
and so what you see is just like the
data were showing is that with ICMS
feedback as much we're confident in
reaching towards and grasping the object
and initiating that transfer over to the
race surface whereas without ICMS often
he's sort of taking extra time to
position the hand to ensure that the
grasp is going to be successful so now
we can play the video
okay and hopefully that video gave you a
sense for you know how ICMS feedback can
actually improve performance and so even
though you know Rob started out by
showing you that you're using this
decoding scheme we can achieve high
performance with visual feedback really
what this study shows is that BCI
control without somatosensory feedback
is impaired right and here I'm showing
you again one example of how we
quantified that in terms of a reduction
in completion times when we added
sensory feedback but this lines up with
what people have observed you know in
other cases where for there's a
neurologic condition that results in the
afferent ation or using sort of the
surface anesthesia to anesthetize the
digits where people are able to do tasks
and have able to perform movements
without sensation just using vision but
they're impaired when you when you take
that away and we think that I see a mass
of a very one X amount of sensory cortex
which is where these electrodes are
implanted is improving performance in a
way that is congruent with natural
continuous feedback and there's a few
different pieces of evidence for that
so first is that when we added this
feedback it improved performance you
know immediately even though he'd been
practicing this task for over two years
which seems that you know it's not
sensory substitution or something that
needed to be learned there was able to
integrate that naturally and improve his
his motor control and importantly when
we took it away it also returned to
baseline very quickly you know another
way that we think that this shows that
it's incongruent is that really the
improvement came from his increased
certainty around grasping so he spent
less time trying to position the hand to
grasp and we know that some of the
sensory feedback typically cues very
strongly to these times of state
transitions when you're going to
initially contact or release an object
and so we saw improvements in those
areas that sort of line up with what we
know from the neuroscience of how
somatosensory feedback improves motor
control and so with that I'd like to
acknowledge our large team just three of
us have been here talking today but
really there's a lot of work that goes
on to this thinking our students and
postdocs as well as our faculty
collaborators and of course we could not
do
to work without our study participants
you dedicate an extraordinary amount of
time to helping us learn the
neuroscience that goes into developing
these devices to restore berlín function
so thank you